hello and welcome my name is Jake I'm
here with John Luke we are taking a look
at the far cry 5 arcade editor I'm a big
fan of map editors and games yeah Sam I
spent actually a lot of time on the Far
Cry 2 map editor on PC and this seems
pretty similar but like they've just
added so much more which is actually why
I'm really stoked about this
yeah I've been playing around with it a
little bit yesterday in a little bit
today and so far it seems pretty cool
there's a lot you can do with it
so we're gonna kind of go over the
rundown the basics if you will of it
because it is kind of complicated if you
haven't played around with it before now
just one thing I do want to preface is
that I'm not an expert I'm not gonna I
don't make some like amazing Maps you
see online I've just played around with
it enough to know the ins and outs but
yeah I'll try to help you guys anyway
give people the basics I can't but
anyway as you can see here we are we're
gonna start with a new map this is also
PC so if you're playing on console this
may not be as helpful but hopefully the
tips and practices we go over should
help you there right yeah so the same
ideas they all still apply but that map
editor reminds me more of forge this one
seems more like almost an actual it's a
separate program like you have to launch
something else
so first mission type I'm gonna do we
should do either assault outpost your
journey
what's his journey journey just means
you gonna get from point A to point B
okay
or or bounty hunt because team Team
Deathmatch and deathmatch I will I won't
mess with AI so right probably wanna or
vehicles I don't think yeah just go
ahead and pick one all right we'll do
outposts and then you can pick the
terrain we're gonna start with an empty
map because you can actually make
terrain pretty quickly in this game if
you know what you're doing as you can
see though we've got a really boring map
here so first thing we'll do is let's
pick a terrain we'll change this
throughout it all look at all those
options there's a lot of options in here
that aren't even in like five like
there's snow you can make a snowman
should we do snow we should I think the
snow is pretty cool-looking actually
okay we'll do snow
oh shoot okay so here's a trick right
here so I can just change let me remove
this but I can just change this see
click the small - god yeah and then I
can change all of it
so snow grass grass bottom - awesome
there we go wanna do proper snow yeah
let's do some proper snow actually yeah
there we go about some glaciers just
snow snow one it's no three this looks
good yeah there we go oh all right okay
so we have that we can adjust weather is
well here uh time of day time a day how
about it's that evening sure yeah yeah
that's going change time it's a Sun
angle mess with this one and moon phase
Wow
yes if you do not you can change size
you can't do Sun size it looks like
actually let's do night so we can look
at the moon and then look at this
wham-o that's cool and I love that yeah
and then you can change ambient color it
doesn't affect it a whole lot I've
noticed I can see a little it's kind of
yeah a little bit of a tint we'll turn
that back down to zero and we'll do day
just so it's easier to see at it and
then maybe change it at the end yeah
that's usually something you want to
change at the end and obviously there's
other settings you can do in here sky
clouds you can even turn on a storm uh
make it stormy yeah let's go back to the
I feel like no clouds so it's kind of
dressing at the end maybe yeah okay so
the next thing that I typically do is I
add vegetation okay so vegetation is it
works very well in this it's same thing
I think they did in Far Cry 2 but
basically you pick sort of a type of
crickets do snow tree cuz that makes
sense
so here our options here snow no grass
uh next maybe yeah where'd you see mixed
snow mixed three so that's no mister
okay spruces Wow so Vic oh you just
paint them like it's super easy man it's
like a speed tree
yeah and if you've noticed so if you
hold shift mm-hmm you can move quickly
oh that's good if you don't hold shift
you move very slowly yeah I wonder if he
could even even the shift it seems lolz
you can adjust it down here so this down
here I can go to I can do custom I can
make it oh geez Oh 50 not that custom
will do I think I have it at 20 on my PC
oh yeah yeah there we go it's a little
bit better already that's looking pretty
good
you know gonna have to do that much at a
couple more trees yeah
one thing I've noticed when I've we
played a couple yesterday one thing I've
noticed a lot of people keep the flat
terrain now I would recommend right not
doing that so there's a whole bunch of
different ways you can adjust terrain
you can do the bump tool you can do the
raise the lower tool you can do the
flatten tool the ramp tool terrain set
height smooth so I usually at first at
least just go with the bump tool and
then I make the radius nice and big and
I just kind of you know bump just try
and give it a little bit of texture on
the ground yeah we'll leave it I won't
do much more we'll just stick to this
little area here there we go we've got
you know we got little mountains and
valleys in here cool it it definitely
adds a lot and if you want to test out
you can go to game Explorer map all
right check out our forest I don't know
why it does that every time you learn it
but thing that windows noise pretty much
it does it every time
well that's annoying but it is stops
after a while but see there we go so
we've got some elevation we've got a
nice dense forest wow that's really
annoying why is it doing it we should
add a building yeah instead of build it
was let's add like a cabin can we can we
put like a log cabin in this voice so
we're gonna go over here objects and you
can sift through a ton if there's a ton
of stuff you can go through Far Cry 5s
darker or not in fart
normal Fargo cams
watchdogs Assassin's Creed Black Flag
unity there's a lot at your fingertips
what I would recommend doing is once
you've found that just scroll down
search so we want to add a cabin it's
typing cabin hope they have it can it
Mandan cabin abandoned cabin camp ooh
maybe that one we've got a lot here oh
geez
Wow yeah a lot of these are cabinets
though all right well let's do yeah I'll
see that one cabin camp maybe yeah a
cabin camp we'll do this one all right
what did I do to it oh wow there it is
let's put it outside the forest right
outside okay so pretty simple I have it
right now I just click to place it but
chances are you probably not gonna want
it you probably gonna want to turn it
adjust it a little bit sure so up here
is where you can do it so this is
positioning so I can grab it move it
around what I like to do is you can see
these arrows down here so there's the
blue one the red one and you can click
in so this means it'll only move on this
plane if I hit the yellow right so it'll
stay there if I want to raise it I can
click this one right here and it'll only
move up and down a little bit left to
right and then there's the red one which
means it'll move like that you can also
click on the arrows if you want finer
movements but what you'll probably end
up wanting more is the rotate tool and
basic rotations will rotate it so it's
facing us pick it up and there we go so
we've got a nice little cabin right
outside cool woods we should we make a
road we got paths we can it's Gavin yes
so once again through the four here we
got a road let's get let's get on the
other side of the forest here and all
right so we've clicked on the road add
road what kind of road are we thinking
probably a snow he wants snowy road no
paths no tracks mmm snow paths gravel
maybe
okay yeah we could do that okay so there
we go
and now we're just drawing I can't see
the yeah it just deletes the yeah so it
cuts right through the trees which is
super nice let me get a better view of
the cabin so I can make all right there
we go and I believe you can tweak it
yeah so it's kind of janky a little bit
but you can add more points around and
tool anyone who's familiar with like
Photoshop or illustrator yeah and then
we can also do is we can adjust Road
width so we can have a big wide road and
then I'll get rid of some more trees in
the way or we can keep it small I think
you know probably this will be pretty
thin cuz you know there's been some
heavy snow right might be tough to get
through uh let's walk our path how about
that make sure it's good looking okay
alright so you can't see it that well
kind of like that though it's subtle
yeah it's snowy you know that's what you
want but it kind of creases yeah crazes
path to here and here we are I mean like
I think the most useful thing about it
is that it clears the the trees and
everything out of the way right so there
we go we have our path to the cabin and
you can add like individual grass and
and like yes actually we should go over
yeah let's add let's add some more
vegetation okay um
it's what snowy ones do we have snow no
grass I saw they had some trees over the
top like Brax black spruces and and
birch trees uh
where'd you see that snow birch and then
black spruces so here we go this one
yeah or snow blocks whichever whichever
works so same thing you see it'll cover
up the other ones but it still won't go
over the road which is nice so it's like
the mixed one basically took like all
the different tree models and kind of
combined
yeah and it's like oh if you really just
want the spruces it'll it'll do it this
way yeah and of course if you make a
mistake
always got command-z perfect okay let's
say this is you are recreating the
revenant okay
revenant - revenant harder so we needed
some bears we need some bears we need
multiple bears okay so so you're gonna
click AI uh it's freezing up a little
hey I and then click on animal all
perfect and once again if we scroll down
here we can search stewed bear grizzly
bear an American black bear
oh right grizzly yeah look at that guy
put them right here and then we'll spin
them this way it's placing another one
so one thing you can do is you can click
on add multiple objects and what that
will allow you to do is go back to bear
so notice how I have to like go back
here and do it yeah this just lets me
zoom this is this is a pretty useful tip
I'd say yes especially when you're
you're placing enemies or yeah yeah you
meet rocks wrong one so yeah you're
gonna want that box checked if you plan
on placing a lot okay so we've got some
enemies how about we place dude at the
cabin to a guy who lives there okay okay
so we're going back to AI enemies allies
should be an enemy or an ally I feel
like you should be an ally like we're
trying to help him kill the Bears all
right so we clicked on allies we can
okay yeah there we go
so we got a lot to choose from here I'm
pretty sure but animals and allies are
the same just whatever you pick with
that daredevil all right oh the revenant
- right here yes all right moving in
this cabin okay so we got this guy now
what can we make him do so there's four
options there's you or there's three
options you can do an animation point
control zones or navigation mesh
basically it just kind of determines
what your character that you just placed
will do when you're not interfering so
if you interfere then it'll get all
thrown off charm but we'll do avocation
animation points quickly and basically
what this means is that when this
character reaches this point he'll do
something so why don't we actually why
don't we go back to objects why don't we
add a campfire and we'll have him like
getting warm at the campfire okay there
we go we got a little fire in front of
the cabin and we'll move our friend here
there we go
smoke blown right in his face perfect
okay so helmet on yeah he'll be fine
we'll go back to AI now and we're gonna
go to animation points and we're going
to owner if we can search we may not be
able to search on this one no we can all
right I think it's fire shut here we go
a guard stand camp fire we'll do this
one and we'll just place this animation
point here one thing that you want to
make sure of is if you look at the
animation point you can see the arrow
you want to make sure that arrow is
facing where you want him to do the
animation so you can do it backwards as
it is now that's an important tip but
anyway so we've we've done that we have
an AI character we have some bears we
have a little bit of terrain uh we could
mess around with time of day maybe we
could go back to there yeah I wants to
the moon okay
so I get nighttime as I kind of teased
earlier go to time of day make it night
where's the moon there's the moon we've
already made it big do that
and then when should we turn up the
winds turn up the wind can you give
everything like a like a forest blue
like you they're kind of that blue tint
yeah I think ambient color blue yeah
maybe not that blue yeah it's that's
very blue oh that's wrong one
yeah like that just like you know
all right well moody um
cloud shadow oh wait that's cuz clouds
here we go let's make it cloudy dang it
oh there we go oh and you still see the
moon oh now I can see all the shadows
all that's starting to look nice okay
and we could do a storm to you can't
really see it in the editor but when
you're in the game you can see it rain
oh and there's lightning as well and
then we can add fog if we want oh wow
and then post effects Oh bliss oh wow
Hey
look how this is Greenland gonna movie
style oh that's bad maybe it's like a
foam grain - it would be still - that's
not like bad movie style one night all
right I saw they had shangri-la like
from Far Cry 4s an option oh yeah it
different color I think that I do
remember that color in the end
shangri-la uh what's the thing at the
bottom after this there's an audio yeah
so this is won't you sake yeah you can
set the music will do I mean you can
hear the forest or Thor oh sure
music theme so far cry 5 songs
uh please just [ __ ] oh you should play
the blood primal blood dragon soundtrack
alright cuz it's good okay
it's droppin now look at that
it's a moody a moody little spot the
trees are blown in the wind that's
pretty cool cuz I turn bears look at
that man you made it you made a video
game thing yeah of course we're not done
yet though so this is an outpost one so
that means we do have to have dudes we
have to kill all the dudes and then we
should also place alarms and spawn
points so first we'll start with spawn
points
so basically spawn points are objects
well actually first I'll go over to the
validation thing so we can't play it
because no snapshot has been taken okay
there are no alarms we need at least one
there are zero spawn points and we need
at least one enemy AI and reinforcements
wave okay okay
so we have our work cut out for us at
the moment
but let's go to let's start with the
spawn points so actually here we go this
this one has our objectives right here
so there's an alarm will place the alarm
since it's here first we'll place it
near the cabin cuz make seems like a
good alarm spot we'll turn it a little
bit here perfect and okay there we go
and now let's add a spawn point so we'll
put two just in case we want to do co-op
let me turn these this is gonna be right
in front of the Bears I'm not delete
some of these bears
there's also hotkeys for these buttons
so three you can do rotate okay - you
can do move and basically they just
correspond with the toolbar up top
all right so we have to spawn points now
do I need to do two players spawn points
area might not because it's cuz there's
bears whatever at least one of me AI in
the reinforcements wave sorry hiccupping
okay so now let's play some more enemies
just so there's more to do will do
enemy security why not and as you can
see there's a wave setting here so we're
just gonna do wave one for now add
multiple objects
okay and then we'll go to wave 2 so
basically this just means if they set
off the alarm these are the people that
show up mm-hmm all right so now let's
check our so we've got everything except
snapshot let's take a snapshot now it's
not just like image you would see yes so
this is when you're looking at other
people's maps and you see an image so
there we go get a nice image of that and
capture oh look at that
there we go we got our image we can add
a tag or just call this difficult no
Airport Zoo survival assic classic
island we'll call this out one sure why
not snow island you probably do want to
spend time on that just to decide what
it is so people right who's search know
but you know we're not gonna publish
this well we're not gonna publish this
for the world to see nah all right so
now I've been hitting Explorer map an
explorer map just lets you drop in no
matter what now I'll do play map I guess
I can go over you can change the
loadouts
to change that as well oh okay cool so
here we are now everything's gonna
attack me
okay you can maybe avoid the Bears see
if you can stuff around
but here just growling at each other oh
I can hear that blood dragon dragon
music - oh yeah that's what I want all
right - have any grenades yeah I do
now that
no alarm all right fantastic
so but as you saw we started we had a
load out you can change that if you
click on this and there you go you can
pick load outs we'll just do assault for
now weapons slot you can even customize
the attachments Wow
yeah so we'll do all Oh clear
yeah well clear the loadout it's all
empty right now and I believe you can
also leave weapons on the ground as well
for people to pick up you can yeah pull
for multiplayer not only that so let's
do so that is in gameplay weapons and
ammo here you go Oh perfect yeah
rifles rifles you can place 50 cals
shotguns LMGs plus you can also do
vehicles and it's not just driving
vehicles you can also do air vehicles oh
sweet let's spawn a plane we'll put it
on this flat land we have outside of the
forest one last thing to that I do want
to mention is that you can also choose
the map limits so as you can see here
the limits right now ah it's same thing
with the road I can shrink it down okay
so maybe yeah if you want something
smaller limit the map and then find a
way to barricade it also people don't
try and leave the map yeah exactly and
then it's also good to check your budget
every now and then to see how much
you're using oh so that that tells you
like things are gonna start to slow down
once those get up high so usually it's
good to make a small map especially if
you want like a nice dense forest like
we have here but yeah let's jump in map
fly this plane observe our beautiful map
from the skies this is not the kind of
weather you would fly a plane and no
it's not come on get up there go it
doesn't want to go up either oh look at
that beautiful little forest and crap I
can't die so just get down oh it's okay
you're warm now though you can use the
yeah exactly so those are the basics
obviously you're gonna spend more time
than we just did now but once you do
have something that you are proud of
that you would like to share make sure
to save it of course will save this test
and then you go to file and you click
publish map it'll tell you make sure
there's nothing offensive you'll hit
okay and you're done
its life anyone can play it awesome yeah
and then these maps are I know pretty
easy to search for in the game you can
just go to in-game and you can just
search by like map name or creator name
so it's pretty easy for people to find
your map if you want them to and yeah
I'm actually I really dig these tools I
want to mess with it more myself and I'm
also really curious to see what the
community makes with this I feel like
it's only been out for a day I'm already
someone who's like recreated a map from
counter said right you're like dust2
from counter-strike which is pretty rad
a lot of a battle royale map supports of
course which is sure why not oh yeah I'm
this seems really awesome thanks for
showing this off Jake yeah it's cool no
problem
you